[Music]
so are you still trying to protect H
Kim oh my
God oh my
God
get I don't care about about the regular
spot if he dies he
dies last week he got challenged and he
dominated another comedian doing a much
better 60 seconds so he gets to stay a
regular the catch is he has no challenge
this week and what we've learned is he's
not quite always as strong when he's not
being challenged so if he doesn't do
great tonight he's going to get
challenge next week does this make
sense ladies and gentlemen you guys
ready to start tonight's
show 60 seconds uninterrupted you guys
know the words to the
song This is
H
thank you please
laugh thank you
sir I was recently in Nashville and I
went to a museum and I learned that in
Nashville they used to have this thing
called The Negro building which I think
is horrible nowadays we just call it a
basketball
court
I don't understand these people that are
like don't get a tattoo or when you're
older it's going to look ugly who are
these people like man I might not have
had any fun when I was a kid but at
least I have this pristine 70-year-old
body I've never heard anyone be like man
I would totally [__] your grandma but
her tattoos are
gross
I have been buying a lot of things
through Instagram ads I bought that
purple stuff that's supposed to make
yellow teeth
whiter yeah I've been using it on my
skin thank
you well well well it appears as though
we have created an Unstoppable
monster thank you Tony from beginning to
end the pleasee laugh you took all the
tension in the room and let it rip right
from the beginning and then a very funny
joke to close and everything in the
middle the Negro
building yeah it's it's a true thing
it's it's history Jamar I love why would
you have to call out Jamar like that he
was just
relaxing he's chilling he's enjoying
himself on the show you say negro three
times negro juice comes out
[Music]
[Applause]
his hair was flat before this he's just
mad
now Hans Kim you are
[Laughter]
waist I was waiting for your lips to
catch up to your words so
I you did that said like you were here
to avenge your brothers'
death I was waiting for you're funny
thank you Jamar I love you
bro uh Hans Kim doing it again an
unbelievable performance you're wearing
a what is that Phoenix Suns yes you like
the sons no right neither does your
[Music]
[Laughter]
father thank
you thank thank you I'm getting it from
all angles I love it thank you my my
peers and my co-workers loved that
one you get it yes my father your
father's disappointed in you you talked
to your parents recently about your
unbelievable success I mean you he is on
the weekend every road or every on the
road every weekend doing [__] soldout
shows it is incredible yeah he should be
proud of me I don't know I haven't
really talked to him we don't really
talk um
I would love to talk to him more I think
he's a great guy you don't talk the talk
but do you walk the
walk W
okay they're coming in fast people don't
get
lost
stupid do you talk to your mom no I
don't talk to anybody really um they
text uh my mom I text with but my
sisters uh they don't I don't think they
like my comedy they think I'm racist
really yeah
racist are they like are your sisters
like uh very Progressive yeah they're
[__] gay do you ever
wow are they literally gay one of them
is probably gay
wow okay Samurai scissors you know what
I'm
[Laughter]
saying H that's the sound of uh that's
the sound of Asian lesbians eating each
other out right
there there it
is there it is so you don't ever call
your family just to say he I'm sorry I'm
sorry we're going to have to edit that
one out we're going to edit that one
out that's an edit point right there no
all right we'll leave it in leave it in
God damn we'll do it
live what else is going on in your world
Hans Kim you added shows this weekend in
Denver Colorado we did a little show and
uh cam was supposed to be there but he
had to cancel on me um yeah he's got to
do theaters with me his actual dear
leader I love that you're trying to
hijack my [__] own
Creations um I think that's why I came
up with that joke about that building
cuz I uh angry huh I'm jealous of cam
cam whoa the gave the Black Fist on that
one let's go in with our senior
African-American correspondent Jamar
Neighbors on this scene I like how
you're squinting and still need
[Laughter]
glasses hell yeah you are
racist I love it Tony it's actually
really cool to watch Hans GL up I've
he's I've seen him from the beginning
and honestly it was really bad before uh
honestly you watching he was like
watching hacky Chan um and now you're
like jokey
Hank and no I'm serious he's selling out
theaters he's bringing MSG to MSG um
yeah I was getting there there you go
there it
is thank you Mr lowercase
T whoa you just Kim said something and
then you acknowledge Shamar for 45
seconds earlier that's incredible you
just thought of that you were just
brewing on Jamar for a while yeah just
made fun of you and you go thanks a lot
Mr lower case yeah man a call back that
was confusing got
nothing don't don't slam the mic like
that it's a
podcast people go I like the black guy
when he might dro the microphone who
does he think he is these [__] we
have some racist people that uh love the
show and he's on stage right now yeah
sorry about that
Jamar uh can can you just do this mik
Mike drop meat egg
[Laughter]
[Applause]
drop I want you to apologize uh to all
black people right now dear black people
um I'm sorry that I said Little Mermaid
was a shitty
movie
I I hope you get challenged for your
spot for your little
spot say Sushi's bad Sushi's bad
yeah all right well we've even the
scales of everything Hans obviously will
go unchallenged next week
congratulations Hans thank you Tony this
whole putting pressure on you thing is
uh really really uping your game I like
it a lot I think you do too I think it
makes life a little bit more stressful
but it's not easy and uh you're a
shining star Hans Kim ladies and
gentlemen there he
goes all right we have a bucket pole
ready to go that we pre-picked uh a
second ago there going to be our next
one so are you still trying to protect H
Kim oh my
God oh my
God get him
bringing get him
[Applause]
[Music]
if Michael settle down over
there Jesus
Christ battle drums really I don't I
don't care about about the regular spot
if he dies he
dies so wait a second you literally are
leaving the United States of America
next week yes sir and you have one more
money Monday left in town one more
Monday to take a man's
[Applause]
job I love what is this it doesn't make
any sense though if you win you won't be
here would you
stay he has a job working with the
[Music]
EU that's what I said when I he came out
here I was like
pu that's not what you're going to say
later
tonight
yeah I'm going to be saying someone call
911 oh [__] listen hansim is selling out
theaters all over the country I did an
open mic at a
pizzeria I feel like [__] it that's why
I'm doing it I don't give a [__] where
this takes me I'll see I'll see what
happens when it happens but Hans Kim was
was doing an open mic in Pizzeria just
yeah two years ago yeah me
too I two years ago I was doing open
mics to an empty crowd in a strip club
in
Bangkok very specific I I don't so what
do you want what exactly do you want if
you became a regular you'd have to go
back to Brussels you can't afford to fly
me no what you want me to fly you every
week to from Brussels to Austin I'll fly
myself if you can't afford it what are
you talking
about oh my God this guy's unbelievable
I am GNA [__]
[Applause]
him
[__] [__] him Kim we finally found a way
to keep him in
[Music]
[Applause]
Europe he's going to need that free
health care after you're done with
him kidding I'm kidding shut up and the
unemployment
benefits so Rick seriously explain to us
what the battle plan would be if you
beat Hans Kim for regular ship if Hans
Kim beats me because he brings his a
[__] and he gets his act together and he
beats me we'll see what happens if I
beat him what do you want I want I'll
give him an an honest
rematch at New Year's Eve that Arena god
listen to
that
I [__] love this
idea now you've sold me on it now
there's a little story line there's a
little punch to it you know what he had
a great set tonight but absolutely Hans
sorry
bro next week your final week in town 60
seconds versus 60
seconds for the regular
ship it will be Rick Diaz versus Hans
Kim to start start next week's show and
if Rick
wins Hans stays the
regular but they battle on New Year's
Eve in front of over 8,000 people at the
HB what if Hans wins and he loses his
golden
ticket
wow wow red band with you only get that
one one out of every 300 times he talks
folks I don't know how many of you are
real fans of the show but the king of
bad ideas just showed that every once in
a while he can dust up a good one how
does that sound to you will you put your
golden ticket up on the
line now let me remind you if you lose
that means you don't get to go on every
kill Tony that you want but if you win
then you then you battle again and if
you beat him on New Year's Eve you're
the new regular and he's gone so you
become a new regular this gives you a
chance to go back to Brussels put a
ribbon on things
[Applause]
and look at this guy natural chop is
[__] star soaking it in building
anticipation calling off the band and
here we
go
if I lose [__]
it no [__] you idiots shut up you
[__] trash people yeah if I lose it's
okay I got the golden ticket nobody can
take that away from me if I lose it I
don't give a [__] but I want a chance to
recapture that golden ticket at New
Year's
Eve okay I get it I love it it sounds
like two great [__] showdowns to me
next week Rick Diaz versus Hans Kim to
start the show but but if you failed to
get the golden ticket on New Year's Eve
you're never allowed to be on kill Tony
every no no you're done righted there
you go right back to bad ideas there he
is everybody you can set it to a [__]
clock this is like the [__] UFC yeah
it
is it is it's it's if the UFC took the
SAT that's what's going on here you
ready Rick you got it next week minute
versus minute I mean fansim had five
punch lines tonight
yeah my last joke tonight had five five
had five punch lines wow look at
that I don't give a [__] I came here
having nothing where's Hans is Hans up
there I came here having nothing if I
leave with nothing I'm good with that
where's Hans
at we got eyes on
Hans this is hilarious hey I want to see
this face off going we it's okay we have
a scale back there can we get the scale
we'll have these guys weigh in give me a
scale give me Hans
[Music]
Kim by the way it's 70.7 de F in the
room if anybody was wondering 49%
humidity I still I still appreciate we
there
[__] and he is not smiling by the way he
is not smiling get in there Yoni all the
way in straight
across oh my god
oh oh my God huh holy [__]
everybody wow look at this Hans step up
to the microphone Michael relax Jesus
Christ this [__] guy's on goddamn
testosterone over
there
relax
dude oh my God let me tell you guys
something all [__] uh all
entertainment aside Hans absolutely
hates the fact that I challenge him on
his regular ship it bothers him
tremendously but he does see the results
week after week after week of the
pressure it's how diamonds are created
and here you go you have this Rick Diaz
who for two weeks in a row keeps
dropping your for no
[Laughter]
[Applause]
reason there's nothing funnier if you
know him than a mad Hans Kim by the way
what you're seeing is real he can't he's
not an actor this is you see that smile
how would you like it if someone came to
your job was like Hey I could do better
at your job I challenge you a guy that I
invited into my home he played Katan
with me and my girlfriend I did a
podcast with them and these are what
Europeans are like don't turn into this
you are American you have a backbone in
a spine oh my
God oh my God I love the nerd off you
guys are having it is incredible I
invited him to my house to play
Katan I let him use my retainer when he
went to sleep that
night I swear to God I gave a 20% off
Lens Crafter
coupon I let him borrow my [__]
calculator he needed to do a m problem
computer
modulators I this is really going to
Dungeons and drag
on hey that is true I hope Rick Diaz
wins because he's less
racist oh
[__] when you come to a dork in the
road
Hans Kim what do you think about this
challenge now I don't know if you caught
it but here's what's on the line Rick
Diaz versus you next week and basically
whoever wins nothing
happens but there's going to be a
rematch on New Year's Eve in an arena in
which either you win and you take Rick's
golden ticket from him technically this
is like in pro wrestling when someone
has both the heavyweight championship
and basically the Intercontinental
Championship at the exact same time you
would have a Golden Ticket which would
mean nothing to you other than the fact
that you took it from some European that
thought he could take your
job let me remind you Hans that you are
beloved on this show and every single
time I believe you're what six and0 all
time in challenges it's a
record why is it
padded padded why is it padded explain
to us why I love that you two hate each
other people less than one year of stand
up how long have you been doing it four
years oh my God Hans how long have you
been doing it 10 oh [__] look how pissed
he is some of you might not be able to
see it maybe you need to know Hans a
little bit better like I do but that is
his [__] furious face I mean right
now now he's smiling but you're going to
see it's going to go right back to it
watch Rick say something say something
Rick say anything anything at all
hello oh that's so weird that is weird
oh it's weird cuz he's kind of smiling
most people if they're smiling a little
bit you're like a that person's all
right Hans Smiles a little bit right
before he's about to kill
somebody he's playing that rape game all
right okay Red Band a little bit less
put the mic down put the mic down let's
focus on uh the sound effects or
something so Hans Kim you have a chance
to take Rick's golden ticket from him
why don't why don't we just why don't we
just skip next week and announce it for
New Year's Eve and we'll take care of
business then how about that does that
sound good yes okay yes sir wow Hans is
extra excited about
this New Year's
golden ticket
versus regular ship
wow we have a scale there why don't you
stand on the scale for no reason
whatsoever we have an actual scale
177.1 lb and here we go Rick Diaz is
started my weight there you go Rick Diaz
is going to stand on the scale this is
incredible it's it's not picking up
anything no it's 146.4 away in for no
reason New Year's Eve regular ship
versus golden ticket winner for
basically citizenship kill Tony giving
immigrants of all different shapes and
sizes a chance at uh making it big in
Show
Business Rick tightening the mic stand
just tight
enough there he goes Rick De is
everybody which one did I that one
was okay wow storyline folks New Year's
Eve I got no idea that could go either
way the thing is is r